the mega millions
mystery one month after a single ticket
was sold for
1.34 billion dollars that was the
jackpot right with the b the lottery
officials say no one has stepped forward
and claimed the actual money the ticket
was purchased at a speedway gas station
in des plaines illinois just outside of
chicago it's the third largest lottery
prize ever won in the u.s so the biggest
question is
what's going on did the person lose it
does the person know that maybe they're
getting their legal team together they
gotta assemble you know you gotta get
all the paperwork but sometimes you buy
a ticket and you forget or you buy a
bunch and you lose one could that have
been the case could somebody have known
that that person won i don't know
snatched the ticket well then they would
this doesn't miss it right no one's come
forward the amazing thing about that is
1.34 billion the 0.4 in that sentence is
worth 40 million right think about how
big right right that's how big the
number is